And I'm going to compare the Marxist
theory of suffering to the Judeo Christian
theory of suffering and the
Judeo Christian would be.
And the reason I'm doing that is because
I think the Judeo Christian theory of
suffering is actually one of the
foundation stones of our entire culture.
And so it actually matters why
you think they're suffering.
And so the story that describes the
entry of suffering into the world,
that mythological story
is the story in Genesis,
the story of Adam and eve.
And basically what happens in the story
of Adam and Eve is Adam and eve are
unconscious to begin with.
And they're sort of in this paradise
will state there's no death or at least
there's no knowledge of death.
There's also no knowledge of self.
And then eve eats the apple that the
serpent gives her and the scales fall from
her eyes and she gives the apple
to Adam and he eats it as well.
So she makes him self conscious.
They both wake up.
The first thing that happens is they
realize that they're naked and they cover
themselves up.
And the second thing that happens as a
consequence of that realization is that
they come to know the difference between
good and evil and I mean that's a
insanely complicated story that's dealing
with a re absolutely incomprehensible
number of complex phenomena simultaneously
but it basically goes something like
this is that to be aware that you're
naked is to be aware of your fragility and
your mortality.
When when you have a nightmare about
being naked in front of a crowd,
it means that you're exposed to the crowd,
all your flaws,
all your mortal vulnerability is exposed
to the crowd for for for them to see,
for you to be ashamed
of for them to judge.
That's partly why we're all close.
That's partly why human being human.
Why clothing is a human universal.
There's many human universals by the way,
clothing is one of them although it's
used for many different purposes so Adam
and eve cover themselves up and so
because they've realized that they're,
that they're vulnerable,
they're naked and vulnerable.
That self consciousness,
human beings are self conscious animals.
We're really the only
self conscious animals.
Other animals have the
glimmerings of self consciousness.
Some of them can identify
themselves in a mirror for example,
but we have whole theories of ourselves.
We have whole articulated verbal and
philosophical theories of what a human
being is and what we
each are as individuals.
So really those aren't in
the same conceptual universe.
It's a whole different,
it's a qualitatively different issue.
In the case of human
beings were self conscious,
self consciousness,
loads on trait neuroticism technically
speaking which means that self
consciousness is primarily something
that manifest itself in the form of
negative emotion and we all
know that you're on stage,
you get self conscious.
Is that a good thing?
No,
you can give so self conscious
that your tongue tied,
right?
It's not good.
You don't want to be self conscious
on stage or maybe ever you get self
conscious in the,
in the face of someone
you're trying to impress.
He turned all red.
You Stammer.
It's like self consciousness is a rough
business and it's no wonder because you
know yourself for the f for
the fragile fool that you are,
and it's even worse than that because see,
it took me a long time to figure out why
it was that when Adam and eve woke up,
they also develop the
knowledge of good and evil.
I just couldn't figure that out because
it didn't make sense to me what,
how selfconsciousness
knowledge of vulnerability
and the knowledge of good and
evil we're tangled together or even
really what the knowledge of good and evil
meant.
But I figured it out eventually I thought,
oh,
I get it.
It was like a real revelation to me.
As soon as you know you're vulnerable,
you know the difference
between good and evil.
Because as soon as you
know you're vulnerable,
then you know everyone else is.
And as soon as you know that
everyone else is vulnerable,
you know how to hurt them.
And so that means you consciously
know how to bring suffering into big,
and that's the knowledge of good and evil.
And you know that because let's say that
you're really good at torturing people,
hadn't,
there's no doubt a number of people in
the audience who are actually quite good
at that,
and maybe you all have a
bit of an affinity for it.
Um,
if you're married,
I'm sure your partner
would testify to that.